la trata de personas para la explotación
sexual es un delito común en la frontera
entre Colombia y Venezuela
miles de mujeres venezolanas transitan
los cruces ilegales cada día y un número
desconocido son captadas por grupos
delincuenciales
Angie hará que ha vivido aquí toda su
vida es la funcionaria del gobierno
encargada de la lucha antitrata de la
zona con miles de personas que están
dejando de ser asistidas de un apoyo que
se les debe estar brindando son personas
en condición vulnerable pero en su
municipio Villa del Rosario solo hay
nueve casos reportados oficialmente
hacen parte de los apenas 17 que ha
documentado el comité de lucha antitrata
de la región de norte de Santander este
año muy pocos para justificar recursos
del Estado los delegados de las
entidades estatales de protección saben
que los casos son muchos más pero no
tienen presupuesto para perseguir el
delito y sus contratos duran pocos meses
serán reemplazados antes de poder hacer
su trabajo unos pocos como Joyce ropero
que gozan de mayor continuidad dan
cuenta de ello en contra de esa llega
nuevo entonces toca empezar a retomar el
tema capacitarlo prepararlo y eso tiempo
sí porque la persona tiene que empaparse
el tema hay que leer las normas hay que
leer los decretos hay que leer toda la
información que hay al respecto y trata
cuando esa persona no continúa y llega
una nueva persona pues tenemos que
iniciar el proceso nuevamente Pese a que
la trata ha sido llamada la tercera
empresa criminal la más rentable del
mundo en Colombia se hace poco por
combatirla el Ministerio del interior
lidera la estrategia nacional con un
escaso presupuesto anual de unos 500 mil
dólares como resultado en 2021 solo se
reflejan 181 situaciones de Trata a
nivel nacional
112 con finalidad de explotación sexual
los números se quedan cortos la
periodista María fitzgerald ha seguido
el tema de frontera señala que las
autoridades no entienden el delito o son
Cómplices de él
los mismos personas los mismos
patrulleros de migración Colombia las
amenazan con votarlas a la frontera Sino
les pagan coimas o si no se acuestan con
ellos o si no les sirven de alguna
manera Entonces si la misma
institucionalidad está tan corrompida
como para terminar trabajando en medio
de estas redes Pues que podemos esperar
frente a que puedan llevar un registro
juicioso de todas estas situaciones no
lo van a hacer existen Rutas para que
las víctimas lleguen por sí mismas a
puntos de atención pero la mayoría no
pueden denunciar de las rutas de
atención no entienden las circunstancias
de las personas entonces ellos ponen una
app sin entender que muchas veces son
mujeres a las que les quitan sus
celulares y justamente por eso terminan
sometidas a esto o ellos ponen una ruta
o unas casas de la mujer donde pueden ir
a recibir atención sin entender que
estas son mujeres que están siendo
vigiladas 24 horas del día
son cosas que deberían configurarse de
una manera diferente Empezando por
entender por ejemplo que las autoridades
tendrían que ir hasta las zonas donde
ellas están siendo sometidas las
organizaciones activistas tienen otro
enfoque en Bogotá la ong valientes ha
organizado un día de juegos para mujeres
tratadas y sus hijos Catherine Jaramillo
es la directora general nos habla de las
condiciones de vulnerabilidad que atraen
el delito que a menudo empieza en la
niñez Entonces es como que estoy
encerrada desde pequeña o estoy ubicada
a estar con estas personas desde pequeña
tenemos casos de niños de 11 meses de
nacidos Víctimas de trata Víctimas de
explotación sexual niñas de 12 años
entonces vienen viviendo toda una vida
de violencia que hace que normalicen
estas clases de explotación valientes
educa madres para evitar que regresen
con sus proxenetas de las 28 mujeres que
asisten a los ta actualmente 20 tienen
hijos porque muchas llegan en proceso de
gestación Entonces nosotros tenemos una
alianza con la organización sea más
estando juntos que les apoyen todo todo
su proceso de cómo cómo llevar su
embarazo Qué cambios van a tener en su
cuerpo pero también el momento de la
lactancia que es donde hemos encontrado
un tema de frustración en ellas
impresionante entonces
este proceso cambia cuando es una mujer
que es madre porque Nuestro objetivo
principal es que no se vuelva una
victimaria para acabar con estos
círculos de violencia el conocimiento
del delito tiene que salir de las ong
es increíble que en un país de origen de
víctimas son tampoco los fiscales que
realmente entienden el delito que sean
poco los investigadores que sí saben una
ruta Clara para que los delitos cuando
lleguen a juicio no se caigan los
procesos judiciales son revictimizantes
la sobrevivientes deben contar su
historia de abuso y violación una y otra
vez
la capital intenta hacer la diferencia
la secretaría de gobierno de Bogotá
lidera el único plan independiente del
país con un presupuesto de 3,5 millones
de dólares hasta el 2030 si la persona
es víctima de Cúcuta en chocó en la
frontera con nariño en la frontera con
Panamá en Bogotá puede venir a Bogotá
con recursos públicos de la ciudad de
Bogotá aquí la atendemos
esta víctima quiere ser cobijada
expone su caso a las abogadas de la
alcaldía que activan la ruta antitrata
del gobierno su caso será reportado
vamos a basarnos en los hechos que usted
nos narren y luego podrá evitar
temporalmente esta casa
Ivonne González supervisa la restitución
de derechos de mujeres que muchas veces
llegan con sus hijos en busca de ayuda
tenemos un acompañamiento psicológico y
psicosocial que es un acompañamiento que
se da una vez la persona víctima
independientemente de que venga sola o
con su núcleo familiar cuando la
acompaña en esta medida transitoria
entornos protegidos como este son
escasos aún así reciben pocas
sobrevivientes
la mayoría prefieren acudir a organismos
independientes que han demostrado una
mayor comprensión de sus necesidades
[Música]
en Medellín la profesora Jazmín Santa
aporta sus investigaciones a la causa de
la ong espacios de mujer plazo ong
tienen una gran ventaja Y es que tienen
las voces de las personas sobrevivientes
cierto esas personas que fueron Víctimas
de trata
si si contaran con mayor presupuesto el
estado no facilita las ong la
investigación la prevención la atención
además las ong entienden las
características del delito y su
normalización estamos hablando de un
delito que migra rápidamente Entonces
cuando ya lo estás entendiendo ya tiene
otra forma de captación ya tiene otra
forma de traslado y ya tiene otra forma
de explotación porque a mí me parece
inaudito que una mujer esté en una
situación de explotación cierto la vean
tantas mujeres la vea tanta gente
lleguen a ella tantos hombres
y no pase nada para ella la solución es
prevención diferenciada a las mujeres y
jóvenes empobrecidas un que hasta ahora
no ha existido
[Música]